[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
savings simplified a guide to fume hood
energy reduction
i'm lexi krauss of labyrinths and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by lab conco to learn more please
visit their website at www.labconco.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window
at the bottom of your screen to obtain
your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
casey fulmer pro product specialist at
labconco corporation
casey welcome you may now begin your
presentation
thank you so much for that introduction
um everyone i'm casey fulmer i
appreciate your time to
be able to provide this webinar to you
this is a topic that is
important to me and i'm excited to share
this information and hopefully
you all will will get quite a bit out of
it as well
today we will be talking about the
following subjects we're going to
discuss the brief history of humans uh
where they started
how they've come along and how they've
gotten to where they are today
the energy savings
developments that are available in few
modes and how we
come to those
as well as the implementations of these
options sometimes it's beneficial to
have
more than one
energy saving option
for your for your hoods or your or your
building so
we will be discussing all of this
through this webinar
but we're going to start with the brief
history of fume hoods
a few hits
the concept for the for the
prevention of contact with hazardous
chemicals goes
way way back
there are drawings and notes from from
alchemists that
date hundreds of years before we
came into contact with our first
fumehood
that that shows these similar practices
we find more evidence of laboratory
ventilation type
uh implementation of
practices in the edison laboratories in
the early
would do in those 1900s
is they would actually perform their
experiments in fireplaces so the
building would be warm
and they would put their experiments in
the fireplace and
the difference in pressure from the
inside of the building to the outside of
the building would carry the harsh
chemicals outside
literally whenever
it was it was a hot day they would put
their experiments on the outside of the
building on the ledge of a window where
the wind would
carry those chemicals away so
we start to see a little more
implementation of
of that type of protection
uh in the edison laboratories
the first modern fumehood is actually
credited to
the university of leeds in 1923
basically what it was was a large
cabinet it was standing at working
height and had a vertical rising sash
which was arranged like parallel widows
this is the first time it was kind of
introduced as a sort of
box type build
and then
after that a few of us were commercially
available
from since the 1930s
um in and since that point uh
these
the developments of humans began
and for a while uh after days were
commercially available everything was
great you know females were working
people were
had had a form of protection um
and
everyone was was was generally
safe and even in the 1940s we saw
massive jumps in fume hood technology
where things were developed back then
where
um that are that are still used in fume
hoods today concepts like bypass air and
vid and things like that that we'll
we'll touch on later in this slide were
actually introduced in the 40s
so that's your that's the brief intro uh
to that part of the history a few months
but then something happened
around the 1950s
and that
is
air conditioning
so the concept of conditioning their
cooling air
has been around before the 1950s but
in the 1950s fume or i'm sorry air
conditioning became more commercialized
it's more readily available
it was introduced in in a lot of
buildings people had them in their homes
this was a new concept
and one of the one of the the concepts
that comes with ac is the buildings then
had to be closed they had to be in
enclosed so no more
buildings with open windows or operating
with open doors as they had to
as they had done before
so
with these closed air
closed buildings air then had to be
supplied to the buildings and
that air was tempered
keep in mind
laboratories today
use what is called single pass air so
air in the room that i'm in which is not
a laboratory
uh the air is probably not considered
typically expensive as this area is
recirculated
as it heats up it's recirculated cooled
about four degrees and then
put back in the room to keep everyone
comfortable
but in labs that air comes in and then
it exits
so ac in labs became
very expensive as it pertained to fume
hoods so the tempered air would come in
and the fluids would take that tempered
air out
just for a brief explanation of what
happens to air as it comes into a
building to be tempered just to just uh
highlight
the fact that it's it's an expensive
process let's just imagine that outside
it is 80 degrees
that 80 degree air doesn't just come in
and get get cooled to 70 degrees and
expelled into the room know that that
air could have a substantial amount of
moisture in it
and so that air needs to be cooled down
to below 50 degrees to take some of that
moisture out of the air and then
that now 50 degree air needs to be
reheated
back up to the
to the to the 70 or 68 degree air that
is that is pushing the roof because you
can't just
push out 50 degree air into a room
people will be uncomfortable
this is this is quite the process to to
get the air outside to a comfortable
working
level
in the laboratory
so so all of this expensive air comes as
a lab in the fume hood
having the lab being single pass air
takes that air and pushes it outside and
then the cycle repeats itself all day
every day as long as the cubit is on
there's this implementation of of fume
hoods and and
and
air conditioning at labs and people who
who ran them noticed
man these energy
builds these the consumption by this lab
is is very very high thus the need for a
more energy efficient few woods was born
and so we're going to discuss
today some of these options
first option i want to discuss is the
auxiliary air fume hood
now these hoods were an innovative
design at the time i mean i wanted to
cover it because these are still you
still come up in questions today i still
handle these types of calls
so i wanted to wanted to touch on it
but it was it was a rather innovative
design at the at its beginning it is is
pretty clever and basically what happens
with these hoods is that the air enters
the lab in two places
the first place being the typical supply
air register that's in the lab that was
in every lab and then the second as you
can see in these images
is right in front of the fume hood you
take outside air
untempered and expel it right in front
of the fume hood and the idea
was that the air that was taken out of
the lab would contain 70
of the untempered air so
if it's taking uh only 30 percent of
tempered air out of the lab and 70 is
concerned conserved
thus saving energy
a decent idea but unfortunately
what happened with this design is that
energy energy reduction was
prioritized but safety
was sacrificed there were a couple of
problems with these hoods
the first being user discomfort
so
it with these hoods if you're looking at
this image
the user of the hood is standing about
where the word room air is so that's the
front of the hood
and if you can imagine a very cold day
or a very hot day which happens
that untempered air is blasting right on
the user
so if it's 30 degree air it's right on
the user if it's 110 degree air the user
is experiencing that as well the users
got very uncomfortable
working with these hoods whenever
whenever the
outside
air was
less than desirable
the other issue was that as you can
imagine untempered air it has a lot of
moisture as we kind of discussed earlier
it comes into contact with the air of
the room and then all of a sudden
condensation forms so condensation
would form inside of that supply air
register and
similarly to the expelling of cold air
on on the
operator water would drip on the users
and again that is
less than desirable whenever you are
offering an operating fume hood
the last thing that would happen
and this is the most important thing
this is the primary reason why these
hoods are not are not advised or even
used anymore and that is they had a lot
of balance issues so with these hoods
you have two exhaust or you have two
fans you have one fan on the
supplier right in front of the humid and
then you have a fan on the exhaust air
on
the outside of the building somewhere at
the end of the duct run
if those
fans if those exhaust fans were not
perfectly balanced
they would
tend to
create this harmonic
frequency where they'd be pushing the
other in and out of
of
the operating range which
ultimately
leads to loss of containment and loss of
containment means exposure of the
laboratory personnel
to whatever was being contained on the
inside of the hood and that
as
it pertains to safety is completely
unacceptable when it comes to fume hoods
so for that reason these heads are
largely eliminated
they still exist
because the the life of the hood may
have
been been
expanded
well taken care of
and we we are actually seeing these
being replaced fairly often and
ultimately
this shouldn't be a one-to-one
replacement you don't replace or you
shouldn't replace a an auxiliary error
if you would with an auxiliary or a fume
hood there are many industry standards
that would state this uh similar to
say
c95 but
um
really what should be looked at is any
of the following options
that
offer reduced air flows
um while maintaining safe operation
which is the ultimate
purpose of a female is to keep people
safe
it brings us to option two
this option is the reduced air volume or
rav fume hoods and before we get into
this i want to define a couple of terms
really quick just in case these terms
are new to any who might be listening
the first is face velocity
which is the speed of the air as it
enters the fume hood face this is
measured in feet per minute or fpm
and if you are having trouble kind of
imagining that it's very similar concept
to
uh
to driving your car and how it is
measured in miles per hour so it's
it's a speed or in a duration of time so
there's a single point
and a duration of time
the next term is volumetric rate
also known as sometimes known as airflow
but this is the amount of air that is
being moved through the fume hood over a
period of time so the volume of air over
a period of time it is measured in cubic
feet per minute or cfm
these are directly related
phase velocity and volumetric rate are
related with the equation that you see
here q is the volumetric rate v is the
phase velocity and a is the area of
opening
this is important because
the
the effect of one of these
variables affects
the other ones
so
for instance these hoods are typically
used in a constant air volume system a
brief
description of a constant air volume
system is that no matter the hood
condition the same amount of air
at cfm is being pulled through it at all
times there is no
modularity in the amount of cfm that's
being pulled through it
so
as that is remaining constant constant
or volume
the face velocity is actually changing
which is
really how these reduced air volume
fumes work it's very very simple if you
reduce the size of the opening that air
is moving through
you reduce the amount of air that's
needed to maintain a phase velocity so
if you refer back to that
that equation up at the top of the slide
you can see q equals the a
if you
if you
reduce the area opening by
by half
based on just that equation
the
volumetric rate also
has to reduce by half by a combination
of of those things so
volumetric rate
less air being pulled out of the lab
less energy being used to temper
the air
that is being supplied to the lab
this is this exists in a couple of forms
one is simply just lowering the
operating sash height so instead of
operating at the sash at say
20 inches if you operated the sash at 10
inches theoretically your
your your volumetric rate of exhaust of
that tempered air would be be reduced
not exactly half because humans have
bypasses but
very very close and a significant amount
of air
is conserved by
doing that these are
very common practices
another version of this type of hood is
a is a combination sash this hood has a
sash that
has four panes that moved horizontally
all set in a frame that also move
vertically but
with that sash in the down plane
using the hood through those
the horizontal sliding of those panels
means that that opening is reduced
and and thus obviously as we have
discussed
the amount of air needed is also reduced
this is this is the first option still
alive today in today's market and most
manufacturers will have a version of
this type of hood or
ways to accommodate that
the next option that is becoming more
and more prevalent in the market today
is high performance viewpoints
high performance fuel hoods
are designed to operate
at significantly reduced face velocity
so less air
is being pulled through while
maintaining
very high levels of
containment meaning they keep the stuff
inside the hood at a very high level
while having a reduced disk velocity for
the longest time
face velocity was the standard of safety
the the need was you need 100 feet per
minute base velocity and that was what
determined safety
um
that's that's not necessarily the case
with these high performance humans
which is a definition that's provided to
us to the industry by cepa see if
there's the scientific equipment
furniture association this definition is
the widely accepted definition for high
performance and it is a
performance-based definition if you're
if a fume hood is able to perform
or contain to a certain level on an
ashrae 110 test
with a phase velocity of 60 feet per
minute
in the sash entirely open
it could be considered a high
performance input
these hoods are are a great option for
energy reduction because
if you're if you have a lower phase
velocity
if you remember that that previous q
equals va if you have a smaller base
velocity that
cfm that's required to pull that through
the hood is significantly less
but how do they do these
what about these hoods has been done to
allow such containment at such low phase
velocities well
it's essentially attributed to
performance features
performance features like optimized
baffles which are at the back of the
hood which direct
the hood air flows directly away from
the user's breathing zone
they utilize
airfoils
which
are for smooth air at the bottom of the
opening
there's curved profiles on the side and
tops of the fume hoods and everything is
designed so that air is very smooth as
it enters the face of the hood
there are many other
types of performance features that are
on these hoods but the ultimate goal is
to minimize turbulence turbulence in a
few moment means potential loss of
containment and that just will not do
and the benefit of this is that you have
a hood that is that you
are are operating and being safe while
doing so
and as well
reducing the amount of energy that is
associated with moving that air through
the hood because you're using
less air
but how much less air let's
let's quantify that a little bit
so this is this is an example
everything is relatively
uh arbitrary here um but i tried to keep
what is similar constant as well
and i have this outlined in in terms of
dollars
there's not a great
metric for energy reduction um that that
everybody understands but most people
understand money and so i have
done the analysis in terms of of money
so in this example we are comparing a
conventional fume hood which would
operate at 100 feet per minute as had
previously been the standard of safety
and we have a high performance fume hood
which operates at a 60 feet per minute
base velocity
so
these hoods that are compared both of
them are six foot fume hoods they each
have an 18 inch working sash height
and what we have done here is we have
standardized the cost of cfm per year so
you can see a note beneath the table but
we say the cost of cfm can range widely
from five dollars to thirteen dollars
per cfm
per year depending on location if you
have a really hot location
uh and you have a really cold location
the cost to to deal with the amount of
air exhausted can can vary widely so we
we chose uh typically choose the the
seven dollar range for that but it it's
a constant throughout this presentation
so
um it outlines the the benefits here
as i have stated
uh the conventional fume hoods have a
100 feet per minute phase velocity which
equates to about 800 cfm maybe a little
bit more depending on the type of hood
maybe a little bit less but
the general
concept is is there and then a high
performance hume hood at a phase
velocity of 60 feet per minute requires
only 475 cfm and you can see just by
looking at those numbers what we're
going to
see on this table
intentional fume hoods i have yearly
operational costs five year operation
costs 10 and 15 as well and this is
going to be constant throughout the
presentation that you'll see
and ultimately
you see over over 15 years
running the same exact hoods you're
doing the same thing
except for at a reduced phase velocity
and just by choosing high performance
humans and making sure that your
application allows for the the use of
lower face velocities
save
two thousand two hundred and seventy
dollars a year or seventy five dollars a
year
just by choosing a high performance
keyword and making sure it works with
your application
um over ten years
thirty four thousand dollars that human
has likely paid off itself um keep in
mind this is just this is just one few
months
if you have multiple as we will look
later in this presentation
the
the benefits begin to compact
okay so that's high performance humans
that's that's that's another option
the next option i wanted to discuss
is a variable air volume system
this is a little bit different the
previous options have been exclusively
about the fume hood themselves but for
this option is related to the mechanical
system that the hoods are operating on
so the variable air volume system
we discussed the the constant air volume
system well the variable air volume
system is essentially the counter part
of the constant air volume system or cab
so in a vav
air is modulated based on how high the
sash is and the thing that's kept
constant in a variable air volume system
is the phase velocity
um
so uh how they do this is there are
typically controls on the fume hood uh
sensors on the sash that that are
relaying information to a controller
which are then relaying information to a
a valve in the duct run
and these are highly calibrated
instruments
that know exactly how much air they need
to modulate
through the fume hood to make sure that
a phase velocity
is
maintained this is this is a great
application of
of
of this of this type of energy reduction
essentially
you maintain a a
level of of of
safety here because when fume hoods are
shut
they really should be left on there are
a lot of industry standards that would
suggest that the continuous operation of
a fume hood is the safest
way to operate if you would because it
allows you to maintain a negative
pressure in the fume hood as it relates
to the lab
in
it also helps a la maybe maintain
negative pressure as it relates to other
rooms
uh keeping directional air flows and and
things like that the way that they were
designed to be
um and ultimately just keeps people safe
so
um this increases the the
the benefit of keeping the sashes closed
uh or keeping the hood on when the sash
is closed i apologize
um
because less air is going to be drawn
through whenever that's happened a lot
of times in these in this scenario
nobody's using the hood the vab system
has has a
minimum turn down
and then when the hood is in that
position it automatically goes to that
that turned down
low
and then finally the design phase
velocity is maintained most of the time
or it should be all the time a a risk
assessment's done in a lab and decisions
are made
for what is needed to maintain safety
for laboratory personnel or or equipment
in the lab while the while the heads are
being used and one of the outcomes of
that risk assessment is what face
velocity is needed or to maintain safety
in the
in the hood well if the if the the phase
velocity is not changing as the sash is
moving it's opening it's getting bigger
or smaller
that
that phase velocity which has
has been decided on it doesn't change
and this is very very complex system
that allows this
this number to be maintained quickly
the the main downsides
for for this type of system is that the
startup costs can be higher than
in in typical installations that's
because the equipment associated with it
is an extra
it to what would be a typical constant
airline system
and for this reason most often they are
beneficial on multi-hood installations
um
they can be used on on singlehood input
installations and they are
but a lot of people a lot of end users
notice the
energy reduction benefits whenever they
use whenever they're installed on on on
multiple hoods
so let's take a look at let's let's
quantify the energy savings here again
this is done in dollars
in for this example let's outline the
constants that are the same between the
constant or volume system and the
variable air volume system hood
they are each a six foot hood
they are operating at 18 inch working
sash heights when they are in use
the phase velocity is going to be 100
per minute for each of them
and the same cost per cfm
what is different about the cost air
volume hood is that the hood is always
on and it is
always operating at 800
cfm so no matter what the hood is doing
uh wherever the sash is that hood is
pulling or the the exhaust fan is
pulling 800 cfm throughout it the
variables in the
vap hood
is that
it has operating hours and non-operating
hours for so for this example i chose
it's operating for eight hours a day and
it's not in use for 16 hours a day
assume seven days a week
so the average cfm so if it were to
operate at 800 cfm when it was in use
and 200 cfm when it was not in use would
be the same thing as running that hood
at 400
dfm all day
and immediately just by noticing that
the constant air volume hood is pulling
800 gfm all day you'll notice that it is
half as expensive for for the hood on
the
area variable airbon air volume system
it's not necessarily about that it's
about
half of the air
that is needed to supply for these hoods
is being exhausted you are exhausting
exactly half
of the amount of air on this hood so all
of that energy is conserved
um it's in
it's an obvious depiction of energy
reduction
um
and there's a great option that that
many
are are using today and it's becoming
more and more prevalent as we
go along
the next option and really the last
option before we get to to
combining some of these
is
ductless humids
these are
as far as steam hoods are concerned
these are relatively new concepts they
are becoming more and more acceptable
across the
uh the market um
then they are gaining gaining traction
and popularity
when focusing on energy reduction it's
really impossible not to see the impact
with this type of of human because
it has 100 percent recirculating air so
all of the air that goes into the hood
is put back into the room
there's no ductwork there's nothing
associated with tempering the air that
has moved through this hood
it's it's important though that you
understand that that these hoods uh when
operated correctly can still be a safe
option
they they will have a carbon filter or
some sort of media carbon's just the
most popular
that as hazardous fumes are are coming
in
coming through those filters the the
chemical is captured
and then clean air is recirculated
into the lab
so
nobody in the lab is exposed
um the
the hoods aren't consuming
tempered air
the
the overall impact on the building is is
substantial
and
the benefits are are rather large
one of them being is completely
independent of a mechanical system it
does not matter where the ductwork is
located it does not
matter um if the the building happens to
be really really tall
um and
you need new ductwork for abducted good
these those can can operate there
they're
they're good for that and especially
when looking for
energy
consumption
reduction
no exhaust air means no supply air so if
you're not taking anything out you don't
have to put anything back in to the lab
as it's associated with this hood you
still have to do that in a lab as we had
mentioned with single pass air
but as it's associated with the fume
hood and that's what we are addressing
here today
there's there's virtually no air
associated with that which means all
energy
that is associated with with exhausting
air into fume hoods is entirely
conserved
it's a it's a big deal and
it's a great option especially for
energy star glass
that don't have the the capacity to have
a ducted fume height
i know the main downside with the duct
less fume hood is that
there are limited applications when you
compare them to a ducted fume hood
however
manufacturers of these types of fume
hoods across the entire industry will
supply some sort of
application
review
so you'll you'll
you'll get verification essentially from
the manufacturer of the hood or filters
that
your application is compatible with them
but
the the amount of applications is is
reduced as it's compared to
deducted hoods
but let's take a look at take a look at
what this this uh this means as far as
quantifying the energy savings i mean i
went and just compared it to a to a high
performance fuel hood
because you can imagine the the savings
are going to be substantial
they are it is modified just a little
bit
because
the the the previous example i assumed
the energy required to operate the
systems were were about the same between
the types of hoods um but it's not
exactly the same as it pertains to
ductless units which uh plug into a wall
um
the constants are are the same
uh six foot fume hood 18 inch sash
height i've i've explained all that
the high performance
variables i've we've taken a look at
that ccp per minute 475 cfm
um
the one thing that we are adding here to
this is it's about 800 a year for
electricity to run the exhaust fan
and other electrical uh
portions of this this type of hood
that's important because that's really
the variable as far as
energy consumption goes with ductless
hoods it costs about a thousand dollars
a year for the electricity to run the
fan modules associated with a doctor's
hood
so that's really where we find the
the comparison here um
you assume a thousand dollars a year for
for the ductless hood compared to
the the high performance fume hood which
is
taking air out of the building and
uh thus requiring supply air
um and this is one human just like the
other examples are showing that over 15
years the
the net savings is is rather substantial
at 46 thousand dollars again this is a
this is a generic
um example but it does highlight the the
amount of energy that's been served
by using a ductless hood instead of a
ducted hood when it the application
is suitable
so these are primarily
the the main options that are that are
out there but that doesn't have to be
used independently of one another i've
got a couple of options here where we
have combined a couple of concepts and
then we'll take a look at them
the first one that we are going to
discuss
is is using high performance fume hoods
on a vav system
so this is this is a a great opportunity
here because this type of lap is
becoming
very very common
so let's set up
a hypothetical lab let's make some
assumptions here we're gonna we're gonna
put 10 fumits in this lab all of them
are going to be six foot fume hoods
to address the vav system there's going
to be time when the hood is in use and
when the time when the hood is not going
to be in use
um this slide one assumption we have to
make is that a chemical hygiene officer
for this facility has done a thorough
risk assessment and then they have
determined that these phase velocities
when the is when the hood is in use and
and the amount of cfm when the hood is
not in use are perfectly
applicable to what they need to keep the
lab
and
lab
protected laboratory personnel or
equipment protected
so they have determined that for
whenever they're in use ccp per minute
or exhaust flow rate of 475 cfm it's
perfectly perfectly uh acceptable for
for the
position when they're not in use there's
some hazard that they need to make sure
that they need to keep 200 hood air
changes per hour uh flowing through
those which is about 135 cfm
um other other variables that that are
included in this hypothetical lab
is that these hoods are used 10 hours a
day
five days a week
we're going to be nice within our
hypothetical lab we're going to give
people off the weekends now we're
we're just nice like that
so
what the role the result here
is you have the hoods running at
475 cfm
for 10 hours of a day during the week
and 135 cfm
for 14 hours a day in 24 hours a day
during the weekend
essentially the same thing as running
the hoods all day every day at about 240
cfm it's a reduction
and you can you can clearly see here
let's take a look at what this does
when compared to other hoods on
uh
other systems so
we we have in the left column 10
conventional hoods just so these are
just standard fume hoods they are
operating at 100 feet per minute all the
time they're on a constant air volume
system
and
as you
can
hundred
imagine
forty thousand dollars is no small
number for these ten minutes to be
operating at the the cost just
associated
with moving air through these
spherewoods
um
the other comparison that we have here
is if you just took those 10 hoods and
you turn them into high performance fume
hoods you can see the the reduction here
we
kind of covered that in the high
performance example i won't i won't
outline it here but you can clearly see
a reduction there but
if you have those same 10 high
performance fuels and you put them on a
variable air volume system so that they
reduce air as they are being shut
the the energy savings are
are rather substantial you go from from
840 to 500 000
to then 250 000 to operate these same
hoods in the same
lab just on a different system and a
different quality
uh the the savings are are are just
in incredible uh so
this operates
or i'm sorry this offers multiple
benefits one
you have high incentive to maintain
negative pressure in the do you have
high incentive to keep these hooks on
and maintain safe operation of these
hoods even whenever
the hoods are not in use uh this is this
is safe
you have an intuitive system that
automatically accommodates for changing
sash openings
so you don't have to worry about user
input as it as it relates to
maintaining
as they close the hood they have to turn
down the system or anything like that
the system just does it
and as we have seen
a massive reduction in energy
consumption so you are
um
you are you are reducing energy
increasing savings
and maintaining safety which are
paramount when it comes to a few minutes
the other option i wanted to to to show
or outline or whenever you combine high
performance odes and ductless hoods
again let's let's take this hypothetical
let's take a new hypothetical lab and
we're going to look at it in a little
bit of a different way um
still using 10 hoods they're still six
foot hood
your safety officer has determined that
the the ducted hoods need to run at 60
feet per minute which means
uh 475 cfm i've this many times now
your lab space is
1425 square feet and the
ceilings are 10 feet tall so we've laid
out the the lab space
and after a thorough risk assessment
your your chemical hygiene officer has
determined that at no time
should your lab have less than 10 room
error changes per hour so this is so a
room air change is how much
uh how many times the volume of air in a
room in a lab
is changed out with new air
in an hour
so this has determined 10 room error
changes per hour at all times whether
hoods are being used or not
what is this what does this mean so if
you if you uh
do a little bit of math that i i am not
showing on on the screen but if you do a
little bit of math
you find out that to maintain that those
10 room air changes per hour
you need to exhaust
200 or 2 375 cfm to maintain that 10 air
changes at all time
which conveniently for this example
happens to be the same amount of air
that will be moved through five high
performance six foot few moments
running constantly so what does that
mean
it means
that if you have your high
high performance units you need five of
them you run it at this that phase
velocity that you have determined to be
safe
you exhaust that that 475 constantly
your room is now safe because you've met
your 10
air room air changes per hour
and your hoods are operating at a at a
condition that your your safety officer
is determined to be safe it was great
because what does that mean for the
other five hoods is that they can be
ductless you don't need energy
associated with moving through those
hoods as long as the application is is
acceptable with a ductless hood
these are essentially free hoods to the
lab space
now this is this is this is exceptional
because you don't have to accommodate
for
um
for for additional exhaust running
through these hoods
and your your your room air changes your
your laboratory
room air flows your building airflow
directional airflows all of that is
maintained
and and now you can have
five hoods that are that are operating
ductiles
so let's take a look at
numbers here with with this option of
using the high performance and ductless
stupids at the same laboratory
we already discussed the the 10
conventional heads those numbers are the
same we already discussed the 10 high
performance hoods those are the same
but then let's let's let's take a look
at what happens when we combine them
these numbers what you'll you'll notice
are are rather similar to the other
example
they're almost half of what half of the
energy consumption of of the
the
the previous the 10 high performances
and almost a a quarter of of the the
conventional
the reduction in energies is blatantly
obvious you're not moving
air out of the building with the
deducted duct less hoods you're moving
significantly less out of
the building with the high performance
hood you're getting the benefit of
maintaining your your air changes per
hour that your safety officer has
required
for for the safety of your building
the the the ducted hoods in the same lap
space allow application versatility
because
they can they can handle the
applications that might not be approved
for
for a a ductless wood so you're you're
you're able to to perform everything
that you need to
and then as we have seen on on many of
these slides there is a
massive reduction
in energy consumption of your bit of
your laboratory
in this sense you don't have the install
of a vav system which is which which can
be complicated
so that is a there's a minor added
benefit
reducing your your energy consumption
you're increasing your saving savings
and you're maintaining safety again
that's exactly what we're what you're
looking for with your fume hoods
so if you've seen from this presentation
there are many options for energy
reduction as they are associated with
fume hoods
and you don't have to sacrifice safety
in doing so
i appreciate your time i look forward to
feeling feeling your questions thank you
thank you casey for that informative
presentation
we are now going to start the live q a
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now
just click on that ask question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we're going to answer as many of
your questions as we have time for
so casey let's get started
our first question is
what types of hoods are you referring to
when you say conventional is it both
auxiliary and rav
so when i say a conventional hood
it's more as it relates to the
performance of a hood
with a high performance hood it's been
proven to
have exceptional uh containment
properties which allows it to be able to
be operated at those those lower face
velocities conventional fume hoods
before the implementation of these these
high performance types of uh
features
typically we're only able to
run at the higher pace velocities like
like 100 feet per minute which was for a
long time the standard of safety with
with uh fume hood operation so
when i say conventional fume hood i i
mean if you hood that has not had those
high performance features added to it uh
in
it's operating at 100 feet per minute
because it hasn't been proven to be able
to contain
well enough at lower face velocities to
to be uh to be acceptable in that manner
it's a good question
great thank you casey
so our next question for you is
how does the required minimum air
changes per hour for the laboratory
affect the decisions on the best fume
hoods to install
yeah so i mentioned air changes per hour
a couple of times during this
presentation and
uh honestly there this question uh is
we could have a an entire presentation
on this question alone i mean it'd be
completely different than the one that i
i just presented but ultimately whenever
a lab is being designed or decisions are
being made with a chemical hygiene
officer and an implementation of a
chemical hygiene plan a thorough risk
assessment is done on everything that
needs to be
avoided contained accounted for to make
sure that everyone in the lab building
people people using equipment
everybody's everybody's safe and
something that can come out of that risk
assessment is directional airflows or
room pressurizations of the building
and so
to get that type of uh airflow to get
those types of uh
directional air force or pressurizations
air changes per hour is is just
sometimes a result of that so
if if if there's a risk
present in a lab that
that requires a a substantially higher
uh room change per hour and your hoods
are exhausting a certain amount of air
it wouldn't necessarily
uh
it or there's a potential that it
wouldn't necessarily make sense having
high performance fume hoods because
or sorry not high performance fume lids
but having fume hoods that operate at
lower phase velocities
because you're going to need to exhaust
a bunch of air anyway
so especially when thinking about a vav
system where you're you're you're
needing more air changes per hour when
and when the hoods are not in use so
it's more just of of what you're going
to operate the hood at and if you have
savings available
energy savings available
based on the numbers
associated with the area of changes per
hour
great thank you so much casey
so moving on to our next question
did your cost of the ductless hoods
include the filter costs and about do
you know about the typical cost of these
filters
so the typical cost of those filters
range
widely and i'm not sure i can really
speak to to that sense but
i didn't include the cost of the filters
for the hoods because i also didn't
include the cost of the maintenance for
the ducted hood so we would consider
that a maintenance cost associated with
those hoods
and for the for the sake of this uh this
presentation it was exclusively about
conserving uh energy in in i
i chose uh dollars to to help quantify
those numbers
definitely
the the ductless hoods have that added
maintenance cost associated with them
because ducted hoods do not have those
but as as far as uh the the reduction of
energy consumption uh i i decided to
leave that off because i didn't i didn't
include maintenance in any of the cost
comparisons in the in the presentation
thank you casey for that answer
so looking at our next question okay
here's one for you
so when replacing an auxiliary air hood
with one of these other options what is
the primary concern that should be
addressed
so
with with auxiliary error uh hoods
they're they're often in a building that
was designed with a
an exhaust system that was sized to
to handle a uh
a reduction or or sorry that the supply
air was sized to
uh
only supply a certain amount of air to
to the lab space and if a
a new type of hood is being put in there
it needs to be able to
operate within the
the energy
capacity of of the lab space so
ultimately if the
if the auxiliary air hood was operating
with 30 percent of of conditioned air
that was supplied to the lab the new
hood should be able to
operate within
the the the supply and exhaust capacity
of the existing mechanical system
associated with it
thank you casey we want to thank our
audience for all these amazing questions
that are coming in and we're just going
to keep going with them so
our next one are the filters used for
ductless hoods recycled for a lab conco
program or are they to be disposed for
incineration
they aren't recycled through a
lab conco program but they're
a lot of the suppliers of filters can
can provide some some some form of those
services ultimately
the way that these are disposed of um
depends on
local codes and in certain requirements
in in municipalities
so ultimately that should be something
that should be
looked at whenever
uh whenever considering uh purchasing
one of those types of hoods if it's a
uh if it meets your needs in in in is a
good option for for your building
great thank you casey our next question
should high performance hoods always be
operated at 60 feet per minute face
velocities
uh so
so i i chose 60 feet per minute because
that's the standard uh that we've been
provided that
uh
that is required of a high performance
humid so so a high to be considered a
high performance stream hood you need to
perform
at a really high level on an ashrae test
at 60 feet per minute
so those hoods are are proven to
to have excellent containment down there
however
it's really an application by
application basis you you really need to
evaluate what you're doing inside the
hood and determine
um if if you're uh
if your application allows for the for
the reduction of face velocity based on
what you're doing how you're doing
whatever your process is
uh sops of your building various things
like that some sometimes those those
types of answers are are existing within
a a labs chemical hygiene plan already
thank you so much and looks like we've
got time for a couple more questions so
what is the risk in simply turning off
the fume hoods when they are not in use
to conserve energy
you know that's a that's a good question
um and ultimately uh
there are
uh industry standards that point to
um
the point of reasons why
we don't
recommend turning off hoods and it's
ultimately because
the risk associated with that is risk
associated with a lot of things and
that's misapplication or or misuse of of
of hoods so for instance a a typical
industry
or sorry a an industry standard that
exists and i mentioned it in the
presentation is ansi z95 and they supply
guidance on what you should be
what you should do
before you're able to turn off a hood
and one of those or and it is to have
the hood completely decontaminated and
clean
and then backdraft prevention is needed
in the in the in the ductwork so
the risk is there that somebody
who's using the hood did not completely
decontaminate the the interior hood they
forgot to
clean up something that that still has
residual
hazardous chemicals on it or it has
a
dish or something that that wasn't fully
cleaned out and you turn off the hood
and
all of the sudden you have something
just sitting in the lab off-gassing
hazardous fumes and vapors
which can affect equipment in a lab
the hood itself as it it could be
potentially corrosive
also if there's no backdraft prevention
in place and and the hood just gets
turned off when when maybe all of the
the vapors haven't been exhausted
um if there's a different difference in
pressure between the
uh the room and
and outside that those chemicals could
actually be drawn back into
the lab space so
having the hoods always on is is safe
because it keeps everything under
negative pressure if if anything was not
done correctly you can
ensure that if there's if there's
residual chemicals that is being taken
out of the building and not lingering in
the lab space keeping everybody safe
thank you casey for that answer so it
looks like we've got
one or two more questions here
so
looking at this one since the ductless
hoods aren't connected to a mechanical
system can a customer move the hood from
room to room to cut down how many fume
hoods they need to purchase
yeah so
the answer to that one is is likely not
because there's there's a couple of uh
issues with that
whenever a hood is is put in place it's
certified there
it's tested or should be tested and
certified in the location that it's in
if you're moving a hood from room to
room
the the conditions are are entirely not
the same and there's no guarantee that
the hood will be placed next to a door
or an air supply register or something
like that which may affect the
performance of a hood
in a way that is
um not acceptable or wouldn't be
acceptable if it was if it was tested in
that new space anytime a hood is moved
or repurposed or anything like that it
should be recertified before it's before
it's used
and if you're if you're if you're moving
it daily or or weekly or even monthly
it's it's it's typically not
um
economical to to have to do all that
certification over and over again
so that's that's the main reason other
reasons
oftentimes these hoods have
service pictures
connected to them
which is which is hard plumbing so
uh there's water connected to it you
wouldn't be able to move the hood if
it's got electrical connected to a
duplex you wouldn't be able to move it
uh without without
uh
disconnecting those those uh spots
there are other smaller enclosures that
might be better off used for that type
of application
thank you so much casey and it looks
like that is the last question that we
have time for today
we want to thank you casey for your time
and your important research for this
presentation we would also like to thank
labyrinth and most importantly our
sponsor labconco for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the contact information
that you provided at the time of
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labberts will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time bye bye
everyone
you